and here we go here we
go i just feel like she gets extra
giggling
for me to do this ever since i went
right right it never really works
happy new year
happy mother's day right should we do a
happy mother's day i can't do it again
hi hi we are behind the scenes on
nydj spring summer shoot
spring summer fall well yeah because the
the jeans are good for any season
[Music]
it's kind of yeah very carefree vibes we
have more in common than sometimes i
realize
i love working with them i love doing
anything with them my favorite place to
be
is with my family so for me this is like
i mean i'm happy whenever i'm with them
it doesn't matter from working or eating
or watching a movie or whatever
i'm just happy it's so fun that we get
to do these things together as mother
daughters and you know like
just bounce off of each other's energy
and like a work space
and just sort of have fun and you know
like i i can say to my mom like do you
like this hair do you like makeup i
don't
it's just nice it's just sort of like
having a friend on set
it's a sense of familiarity yeah and of
course
there's always this the thing with me
and sailor where
she worries that she's too tall next to
me and i feel too short
because i might be her big sister but
you would think
you know there's a height disparity so
it's it's fun but i mean i feel like
we all definitely it's very
self-deprecating the mood on set
like we all like jab at each other a
little bit in
in a familiar way yes sir those are my
babies
no sir i don't mean babies i think
something that
people will be surprised about my mom
i think is that she's very chill like i
don't know she has a very
bubbly energetic like personality
but she can really you know she takes
her time in the morning she doesn't need
to like get on a face of makeup and a
full outfit she can chill in her pajamas
and do work and do emails and
and play with the dog and then grab on
some overalls and go to the garden all
day and that's just sort of like her day
to day it's not always
glam it's like being able to go with the
flow
and have some fun outside and you know
get dirty and not
worry about how you look all the time
that's definitely
something that i feel like that's true
yeah like supermodels you think that
they're constantly stressed about how
they look
and like i think with my mom it just
comes really naturally to her that like
if she feels good she's gonna look good
so she focuses on feeling good which is
definitely important i think something
that people don't know about my mom
um or at least i'm always like
introducing even on like my instagram
for example
is that she's an amazing artist she's an
incredible
painter she actually painted oh god was
it 1995
dad's my father's uh you know billy joel
okay river of dreams album which was
gorgeous
and a lot of times like i've put that up
and people like who painted that i'm
like
my mom you know so people don't realize
like
she's really a renaissance woman she's
multi-talented
um and even this is why i keep them
around
no but she has beautiful penmanship as
well like i actually tried to copy like
her cursive because it's so good that
she's very very very artistic
i haven't had cameras in my face i'm an
absolute no on the reality show front
i think that's my worst nightmare in
life is to have a camera follow me
around at all times
and i think that most of us which is odd
because i've had my camera on her
following her around her hole but that's
so different
you know i don't think i don't think any
of us truly would want
our entire lives projected to everyone
else to be edited
and you know like made into something
that might not be 100 authentic to us
yeah if i could pick what moments i
would like to be as shown i'm a little
bit of a control freak for those
as they know but i think um we do
value our privacy and there is something
about growing up
you know out in the hamptons in sag
harbor like it is
a fairly private low-key lifestyle
these two are really
dramatic and feisty and
opinionated and i like the very
theatrical theatrical
you know i like the term opinionated
apparently
so there you go i just love
being their mom you know and i wouldn't
change
any of it at all but
i i do have to look at them and go
you know look at all that power in there
all that
energy that they have when they are
determined
to make a point seven years of tears and
laughter
as you stand outside my door so with
seven years of my new single
it really is quite literal the title
because we've been together
my fiance ryan and i for seven years
and so what better way to title it than
seven years and actually
i i try not to ask my father's opinion
too much on stuff because he's very like
not being a show dad like wants me to do
my own thing but i did get his opinion
and he loved the title
seven years he says that sounds so
anthemic and
um it's a really honest song it talks
about the light
and the dark and the complexities but
really the staying power and the loyalty
that does come with being in a long-term
relationship and i just hope it's a song
that
other romantics can if mom wants to sing
can resonate with and you know i wanted
it to just be like this
hopefully like epic love ballad
um and i hope everyone really enjoys it
cheers
you